15 millions d'euros sur trois ans le
département des yvelines soutient le
château de versailles ouvert 192 jours
seulement en 2020 il aujourd'hui bien
vite de son public et par conséquent en
difficulté financière dans les yvelines
c'est incomparablement le symbole de
l'élégance de la puissance de l'histoire
de la force de l'art et c'est en quelque
sorte un phare aussi les difficultés que
connaît aujourd'hui le château de
versailles méritait que alors que le
département est en train d'aider
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques en
particulier le secteur touristique nous
apparaît c'est normal d'aider aussi le
château de versailles une aide
nécessaire pour le château 75 % de ses
ressources propres viennent de la
billetterie un manque à gagner
considérable estimée à 70 millions
d'euros l'aide que nous apporte le
département des yvelines est fondamental
pour pouvoir continuer les travaux
d'entretien du château de versailles
pour pouvoir développer de projets que
nous aurions auquel nous aurions dû
renoncer si nous n'avions pas eu ce
soutien et comme j'ai coutume de le dire
ce que nous ne faisons pas aujourd'hui
c'est ce que nous perdons pour les
années à venir même si le château est
aujourd'hui fermée au public les équipes
doivent s'assurer qu'au moment de la
réouverture tout soit prêt pour
accueillir les visiteurs
aujourd'hui c'est un lieu qui est fait
pour accueillir le monde entier et on
doit maintenir
jour après jour le château de versailles
en état c'est sa force c'est sa force
pour le monde c'est de cette manière là
qu il rayonnera encore et toujours
devant tous nos amis étrangers mais
aussi pour la france
un soutien qui permettra entre autres de
participer à la rénovation des organes
de sécurité de l'opéra royal et à la
réfection des toitures et des façades de
plusieurs bâtiments